foreign
[Music]
let's
get a speedrun game going
and we have black against random Master
okay D4 nice so finally we get a chance
to play another Rune Felts
and hopefully delve into a little bit
more Theory we've only faced d4c for a
handful of times
okay so the G3 this is the fiancado
variation the fiancaro is an incredibly
reputable uh line it has a very good
reputation it is the choice of a large
number of GMS against both the king's
Indian and the grinfelds and it is
recommended by a couple of very
influential authors including Boris
avruk who's a grand master uh who wrote
a book that for a long time was
considered to be the one D4 Bible the
book is literally called one D4 it's two
volumes I think it came out in 2008 at
first and average recommended the
fiancaro he did some what at that time
was cutting edge analysis and since then
you know this this line is only gained
in popularity of course our setup
doesn't particularly change we continue
with Bishop to G7 whether you're a
grundfo player or a king's Indian player
first and foremost you need to develop
your king side now this is an important
Crossroads because if you are a grunfeld
player then you need to take this
opportunity to squeeze in the move T5
what happens if instead you Castle is
that white often develops the Queen's
night out first Knight C3 and prevents
you from playing D5 so then you're
essentially forced into playing either a
king's Indian uh which is why I normally
Castle in my Blitz Games or you can play
a cross between a grunfeld and a sloth
you can play the move C6 and try to get
D5 in any way but against Knight C3
that's still not a very good move
now it's I put some thought into what I
wanted to recommend against the fiancado
and I actually do want to play a king's
Indian setup because I think learning
the king's Indian against lithium caros
specifically is a lot more feasible than
learning the king's Indian as an entire
opening and the grunfels against the
fanchero is not bad but I've never been
enamored with the positions that black
gets I think white does have a slight
advantage in most lines of the
fiancarenfeld and this will give me a
good opportunity to introduce uh some
nice Kings Indian ideas so let's Castle
and let's put the pawn on D6 rather than
D5 in this game and you can see our
opponent is following The Cutting Edge
recommendation preventing us from
playing D5 but for the purposes of this
game we don't care we play the king's
Indian with D6
and now we enter and we reach another
major crossroads now obviously there's a
ton of different setups that black can
choose and these setups are kind of
divided along two major there's like a
couple of buckets of different King's
Indian setups you can play with E5 or
you can play with C5 that's kind of
bucket number one and C5 is a more
benoni-esque approach that's recommended
by I think gawaine Jones in his
chessable course
and then the second bucket is if you
decide to play with E5 you can develop
this Knight to two different places you
can develop it to C6 where you can
develop it to D7 or you can do neither
and there's a couple of setups that
involve uh playing on the queen side or
get getting your Queen's Bishop out
first or playing C6 and queen B6
literally black has a thousand setups
and I've played literally everything
under the sun for most of my chess
career in this game I'd like to
introduce the setup that I would
definitely call my favorite it's a super
dangerous line if white responds of
course with the main line when our
opponent seems like he will this is a
line which gives black super super good
practical play I beat a lot of GMS in
this line and it does in fact start with
the very King's Indian eskim of Knight B
to D7 and this is also considered the
sort of old school move uh Knight C6 is
a newer move that became very very
popular I'll talk a little bit about the
setups there as well but just in the
interest of time let's focus on the
setup that I'm choosing in this game of
course course the point of Knight bd7 is
to prepare the movie 5 which we now play
and the main line here is E4 why it
responds by controlling the center now
here I play two lines in particular the
line that I play in OTB chess against
other GMS is Pawn takes Pawn so early
trade of Pawns followed by the Knight
jumping out to c-line which leads to a
very interesting setup that is super
common in different King's Indian lines
I'll talk a little bit about it after
the game but the setup that I used to
play and the one that I still play in
Blitz with a lot of success starts with
a very flexible move so we start with
this move C6 and you'll see this move
played very often again across most
King's Indian lines it's just a common
King's Indian move and it's a good
multi-purpose move
and the idea is not so hard to
understand
um of course positionally you are
controlling some important squares but
there is also a semi-tactical idea which
is that you're opening the d8a5 diagonal
for the queen
you might say well why is that important
is the queen really all that good on any
of these squares
well believe it or not it is the oldest
move here is Queen to B6 this was played
already in the time of Miguel botmanik
in the 50s and 60s unfortunately Queen
B6 is refuted by this very tactical move
C5 but there is a second old line that's
quite a bit less known even a lot of
GM's they know about its existence but
they don't really know the main lines
and they don't know how to get an
advantage for white and if you if you're
seeing this for the first time white can
get in a lot of trouble very fast and
the reason though I can get in a lot of
trouble in the fan cutter is because
white controls the Roman Empire in the
set I think white has a lot of Pawns in
the center a lot going on and of course
as in all king's Indian lines we are
attacking that center from a distance
and so it's very very easy to walk
yourself into a situation where your
Center starts to collapse so what is
this move that I'm talking about the
move is Queen d8 to A5 all the way to
the right side of the board one square
diagonally from B6
and if you look up my OTB games you'll
see that I played this line probably
I've had five maybe seven classical
games in this line
and of course this is not a line that I
would play OTB against like Boris avrock
or an fiance specialist but at this
level it works perfectly and I think
it's a great line to illustrate typical
King's Indian ideas
so what exactly is the idea of putting
the queen 98.5 so it's actually hard to
explain there isn't sort of one purpose
the way I would characterize it is is
the queen is
located on a spot where first of all
it's very hard to attack right actually
getting to the queen is very hard
and in this line it moves to a lot of
squares around the queen side sometimes
it goes to B4 in order to attack C4 it
can drop back to A6 it can of course
drop back to B6 so it's very safe it's
out of the way of the other pieces it
has many ways from A5 of exerting it's
like Atlanta or Chicago airport again to
continue our airport analogy
it's not A5 itself that's such a nice
Square although sometimes the queen does
a lot of great stuff from A5 and I'll
show you an example of this after the
game but it's a great jumping off point
that's out of the way of the other
pieces
so of course white has a choice of
different ways to develop their own
pieces Bishop E3 is the most popular
move I think the best move and the way
to really fight this line effectively is
a move that not a lot of people know
which is queensy one to C2 not
necessarily A Move that would come to
your mind if you haven't studied this
line carefully with an engine
uh but curious chimpanzee you came up
with that uh and there's many other
moves a lot of people play D5 here uh
the sort of the instinct to grab more
space and close the center and D5 is one
line in which we can really understand
why the queen is effectively placed on
A5 I have very very good results after
the move D5 because we quickly developed
a rather nasty Queen side initiative by
pushing the B Pawn up to B5 and the
Queen on A5 supports them advance of the
b-pawn
um Bishop D2 I think is an instinctive
move that a lot of people want to play
when they see this for the first time
but Bishop D2 really weakens white
center because it cuts the contact
between the queen and the D4 Pawn so
after Bishop D2 We can quickly try to
win a pawn by taking on D4
white has no effective discoveries like
Knight D5 may seem scary but remember
the queen can always just move back to
d8 and after Bishop D2 Ed Knight takes
D4 there is a type of fork that most
people
see for the first time and I'll show you
after the game Bishop E3 so after a long
think our opponent plays the main line
now the time has come for us to
discharge the central tension if we wait
too long and we play rookie eight here
then white will be able to close the
center and make our Rook look very dumb
on E8 because then it's just biting on
grain under 25 so this we have to take
this opportunity to take on D4
now white has a choice of two recaptures
queen takes D4 makes no sense because it
walks the queen right into a potential
Discovery and we can use this discovery
uh to root out the bishop Knight takes
D4 is the most natural move I actually
think Bishop takes D4 is a very nasty
sideline uh that avoids a lot of the
Annoying tactics that black has after
Knight takes before but our opponent
seems to be very principled so here
again we have a choice of two moves we
can jump our Knight out to E5
immediately uh which is which is a
rather dangerous line uh and it's really
challenging 95 is a very challenging
move that really forces white to display
knowledge or we can play this old school
like I used to play it and first improve
the position of a rook and put a little
bit of pressure on the E4 Pawn Rook E8
is a more flexible move 95 reveals our
intentions but is potentially more
challenging from a tactical standpoint
so it's it's really a matter of taste
rookie 8 I really like because it
actually has a lot of tactical Venom
especially if white plays rookie one so
let's let's go rookie eight in this game
let's go rookie it
let's play um
high level chess
although in my own recent Blitz Games
I've mostly played 95 here because white
is a very nasty move that I wouldn't say
takes this line out of commission it's
still this queen C2
which really dulls down a lot of the
tactics in this line Rook C1 is not a
common move
but it makes a lot of sense Roxy one
just brings The Rook into the game
and potentially in response to Knight E5
white is preparing to defend the C4 Pawn
with B3 of course if you've watched any
Kings Indian games you will know that
this Knight has essentially two pot two
posts that it can jump into can jump in
C5 or it can go to C5 which is even more
common and really pressure the E4 Pawn
but here Knight C5 is less effective
because the combination of the queen on
A5 and the Knight on C5 is very awkward
as you can imagine white can go A3 and
threaten B4 with a fork so typically in
this line the Knight almost always jumps
out to E5 and let's go 95. let's start
with this move let's see what our
opponent does in response and then as we
enter the middle game we will
hopefully continue being able to put
pressure on White Center
so this structure which is similar to
the marozzi bind Against The Accelerated
Dragon which we also play in the speed
run pawns on C4 and E4
is common across several King's Indian
lines particularly the fan ghetto which
we're facing right now
and what is it characterized by well
it's characterized by a big space
Advantage for white
right white as you can see has a big
space Advantage if you are a king's
Indian player you have to be ready and
willing to play Crown positions a lot of
the time and the second thing is it's
characterized by is if you turn on the
engine in a lot of these positions the
engine almost always gives 0.8 or plus
one for white now this is true of the
king's Indian as a whole engine really
doesn't like the king's Indian but as is
well documented by now and hopefully as
you've heard the king's Indian is sort
of an anti-engine opening because the
engine does still often overestimate the
extent of White's Advantage engines like
space advantages and engines aren't able
to tell you how hard a position is to
play from a practical standpoint if you
look at my results in the king's Indian
particularly in Blitz that paints a
completely different picture than if you
look at a lot of these positions with an
engine so
what do we actually do here Rook C1 is
like really really good move by the way
I'm impressed that our opponent knew
this move this this along with Queen C2
I think is the best antidote to the wine
so
in order to justify the king's Indian we
need to play on all sides of the board
we need to be ready to play on the king
side and on the queen side right now we
can't really play in the center because
D5
is really never going to happen white is
defending that square
one two three four times so let's not
even think about trying to push D5
instead we nibble around the edges what
does it mean in the blood on the edges
well one thing we can do is is nibble at
the C4 Point how can we do that well we
can't play B5 immediately because that
blown is a pawn but what we can do and
this is very common in this line is to
start with this very flexible move A6
and it's not it's a low risk move it's a
low risk move because it doesn't really
have any drawbacks
and of course we are preparing them with
B5 now in fact B5 uh is not really
possible just yet uh because white can
push us away with F4 and then the C6
Pawn
is lost after that opposition collapses
but A6 is a very annoying move
nonetheless because now our opponent has
to start thinking about this and very
often people automatically respond with
A4 and of course A4 is a move that we
want to see because then the B3 Pawn is
weak and you might say well that B3 Pawn
how can it be attacked in the king's
Indian you have to do stuff for the long
run nothing happens fast in a position
like this we're gonna have a maneuvering
battle for the next 10 15 moves but
eventually if we create enough
weaknesses and I would almost compare
this to the Hedgehog setup where you
start creating weaknesses and weakness
and eventually something is going to
give right the more weaknesses we create
the likelier it is that when things get
tactical our pieces are going to be able
to exploit those weaknesses
of course the knight from E5 can also
reroute a lot of you might be afraid of
f4 well this is just exactly the kind of
move that we want to see just like A4
because what is the consequence of the
move F4 well we're more than happy to
drop back to D7 again King's Indian you
must be comfortable making a bunch of
retreating moves doesn't mean things are
going wrong after RAV4 the E4 Pawn is
clearly weakened I say well what does
the F Pawn have to do with the epon well
remember once F4 has played pawns don't
go backwards so white is unable then to
play F3 if necessary to support that
pawn anyways
so here we should also be aware that
there is a tactical pattern I already
think that our opponent has missed the
tactic believe it or not what is the
first thing that I see on Queen D2 is
played well there's two things of course
there is the contact between the
standoff between the Queens uh which you
should be aware of especially because
our Queen is undefended but right now
white has no clear way to exploit this
the second thing is forkable squares I
always tell you to pay attention to this
the queen and the King are now on
forkable squares now the F3 square is
protected by two of White's minor pieces
and this is
something that a lot of players struggle
with they see something like this in the
abstract and they say well there's no
way that this could possibly be
exploited but you're often capable of
doing more in the position than you
might think
so we can chase away the Knight by
pushing our C Pawn which is a very
positionally committal move you're
weakening the D5 square but it's good in
the service of tactics the Knight moves
let's say back to C2 or back to E2 and
we of course have Bishop takes H3 very
common tactical pattern that's Universal
across many openings bang we've won a
pawn and we have by winning that pawn we
also forced the exchange of white
svenketto Bishop which further weakens
the center I think we can safely play C5
and I already think we're we're taking
over the initiative now the king's
Indian is so full of these types of
tactical tricks that you could play it
for your entire life and still not
exhaust all of them and this is exactly
what I do so as part of me regretting
not recommending the king's Indian is
feeding a little bit but because we've
had so few games in 1d4 it's almost a
moot point and
maybe we'll do a king's Indian speedrun
at one point I I am regretting a little
bit not recommending it because it is my
own opening that's very near and dear to
my heart
it's definitely not an opening you
should play if you're like under 1200
that's the thing but for players you
know over 1700 or so it is
just a still an Undiscovered gem I think
and I'll talk about some theory in in
our post game analysis
so hopefully you were able to you you
understand the Zen behind this move
we're chasing away one night
and then we take on H3 to deflect
White's Bishop you can consider it sort
of a double deflection
yeah there are some complications there
it's not all that simple
because what you might see if you're a
little bit more advanced is that after
white drops the Knight back and we take
on H3 white has this move f2f4
uh attacking the Knight on E5
and if our Knight moves well then white
can pick up the bishop on H3 and we
don't have the fork anymore and if after
Knight C2 Bishop takes H3 F4 we take on
G2 then you might say well white takes
on E5 and the position is very chaotic
and it is very chaotic and I'm not 100
sure uh whether we Prevail they're
tactically but I have a feeling that we
do right this sounds corny but I almost
I really believe in the king's Indian in
general so when we get these tactical
complications I usually am very
optimistic because we're fundamentally
sound our pieces are very active
the tactics are likelier to work in your
favor if your pieces are fundamentally
more active
yeah King's Indian course definitely I
will make at some point no no question
about that
yeah our opponent I think smells a rat
which is why he's finally taking
quite a bit of his or her time
yeah nothing has been traded Knight D2
okay so let me do a little bit of
calculation here because I have noticed
a small issue with Bishop takes H3
but I don't think it will prevent us
from playing at Bishop H3 F4 Bishop g2fe
Bishop F1 EF Bishop B2 FG
and we drop our Bishop back and we're up
an exchange
but we have a bunch of weak dark squares
on the king side
I'm trying to evaluate this position and
understand whether we get made it I
don't think we get mated but I have to
be sure of it
yeah I think I think we can go for it
also it's just sexy to play this move so
let's play this move Bishop takes H3
okay we take the plunge now for newer
players who are watching this and are
still confused all you have to
understand is that the bishop is
Untouchable why is it Untouchable
because then we have access
to the forking Square F3 Knight E5 to F3
check is a fork attacking the king
attacking the queen at the same time it
is a check and we win the queen for two
minor pieces which is an overwhelming
material advantage in most cases this is
a classic textbook deflection sacrifice
just very textbook and it comes with
benefits in the sense that if white
ignores then we're able to eliminate a
very important piece the fiancado bishop
is what really protects this E4 Pawn
once that Bishop is traded White Center
is going to start to crumble also
White's King is a lot weaker and then
we're just gonna go to town so the the
principled move here that we that I was
calculating that we have to calculate is
F2 F4
Pawn pushes two squares
and tries to boot the Knight out of E5
if the Knight moves away from E5 then we
lose the bishop on H3 so we have to take
the Tactical plunge and after F4 we have
to take White's Bishop
and then white can take our Knight on E5
and attack the other Knight on E6 on F6
with a pawn and the white king is
attacking the bishop The Rook is also
hanging and then the Knight is hanging
so that's a complicated line that you
can only really calculate if you're well
versed in a visualization
and I'll play out all of these moves
after the gaming assuming it doesn't
happen which I think it very well might
and by the way Queen takes D6 is maybe
even the best move
the reason I wasn't too scared of it is
because Queen takes D6 eliminates the
pawn and restores material equality but
I wasn't scared of it because worse
comes to worse we can trade Bishops and
I know for a fact that we have benefited
from the last couple of moves because
this is a weak backward Pawn whereas H3
is an important defensive pawn and we've
eliminated white svenketto bishop and
the Queen on D6 in that resulting
position is super vulnerable is it
possible to trap the queen I don't know
yet but at the very least I see a way
that we can win the exchange so Queen D6
we can trade on G2 and bring our Rook
over to d8 which is the most natural
move now you may think it traps the
queen but it does not because the queen
can take on C5 there
but after the trade on C5 there's a
bishop on C5 and a rook on C1 so we can
hop into D3 with our Knight and deliver
another Fork this time in the D3 Square
hopefully you're able to visualize that
line and we win the exchange that's at
minimum once the position is reached and
this is a very good way of thinking in
general is to come up with sort of
emergency options or minimum options
where when you're assessing a move you
don't always have to find the best
response to it you have to find a
response and if you know that the
position is at least satisfactory you
can safely go through the line having
that response in your pocket now when
the position is reached then you delve a
little bit deeper and try to find
something a little bit better and this
is exactly what I was doing okay so app
for display again if we move our Knight
then we give up the bishop and we don't
have that forking mechanism anymore we
have to take the plunge with Bishop
takes G2 whether it's good or not and we
don't have to waste any time here
otherwise we lose a piece
does that make sense
so again Knight a lot of you are
suggesting Knight E5 to G4 the bishop on
H3 is hanging
and you might say well then we take
White's Bishop but the queen just takes
on E3 and I don't see any tactical
options there
okay F takes E5
so it's easy to get very overwhelmed in
these types of positions in reality you
just have to break it down into its
component's parts what's going on is
actually rather simple we have two minor
pieces that are both hanging the Knight
and the bishop which is why if we make a
move like Rook takes Pawn we lose our
Bishop we will already have amassed two
or three pawns for that Bishop but it's
not very impressive of course there's
also a rook that's hanging and we can
capture it and we probably should
capture it because if we play Knight F6
takes E4 then white recaptures on e4
oh that's also an interesting option by
the way
then we take the queen on D2
white probably recaptures that queen
with the Knight we take the Rook on F1
white recaptures and we take on E5 and
as a result we have a rook and three
pawns for two minor pieces
but we have a couple of weaknesses in
our position so I think we're better
there maybe not winning but better so
that's an option what's the second
option well we can take the Rook
straight away then white will take the
Knight on F6 and threaten our Bishop on
G7
but we can use our Bishop then to take
the Knight on E2
white can only take one minor piece at a
time so white will take on G7
and we will be up in exchange we will
have two Rooks and a bishop against Rook
bishop and Knight in that resulting
position but the drawback of that is
that our King is going to be incredibly
weak because without our own fiancaro
Bishop the dark squares around our King
are potentially fatally weak and there's
a lot of mating patterns there that
could stem from that so the Russian
Schoolboy inside of me says F that let's
just play Knight takes E4 and go for a
better end game and I think that's what
we're going to do because at this level
like I don't want to flirt with disaster
there's no guarantees that we make it
out of that alive I'm gonna give it
another 30 seconds of Silent thought and
then I'm gonna make a decision
okay
okay Russian Schoolboy mode
Russian Schoolboy mode Knight takes C4 I
have a feeling that Bishop takes F1 is
winning for black but
I just had get this sometimes you just
get this sense that
there's something you're missing and
I'll show you I'll give you a better
sense of my considerations after the
game again I can't I don't have the time
to lay out every single thing I'm
thinking so just be patient
this is also just easier to play because
we got three Pawns in a rook for two
minor pieces and the minor pieces are
all sort of clustered in the center and
very poorly protected so we could
actually win even more material in that
resulting position
so
you might say well I don't understand
why white has to play Knight 64. well
it's because the queen is hanging so
white can't take the bishop
Ken white move the queen well that
doesn't make much sense because also The
Rook is hanging so after Knight takes E4
the first tactical observation I made
when we played Queen when white played
uh Queen D2 comes to pass right when the
Queens have this standoff you always
have to be aware of variations in which
the Knight moves away and then our Queen
is hanging because it's undefended so
after Knight takes E4 we have to respond
to the attack on our Queen
and so we have to take white screen it's
the only logical option
then if white takes back with a bishop
we can actually take White's Knight on
e4 and we'll just be up three pawns
that's why white has to take the queen
of the Knight
so
one General observation as our opponent
is thinking is that we've reached a
pretty high level right 2000 plus and
several things change when you compare
our games recently to our games at the
start of this feed run and one of the
main ways that they change is just that
there is just more to calculate the
positions are more complex and
complexity and chess is defined by
amount of variations that you need to
calculate in order to make sense of the
position you can put it that way
now what is how does that actually work
well the openings are more principled
people played better openings and so we
get less of an advantage out of the
opening and the tactics are more
complicated because in general the
pieces are better positioned so when you
develop your pieces much better than
your opponent and you're already winning
out of the opening you don't really have
to calculate all that much everything is
very clear you play by the rules and
everything's groovy here
you know we're encountering more
resistance and that's why visualization
becomes so important at this level okay
Queen takes Queen our opponent is just
taking a second to get his bearings but
he's going to take back with a knight
for sure
okay
so of course now it's important not to
forget to take the Rook this happens
sometimes when there's a lot of captures
a very common blunder is to take the
wrong thing for example Rook takes C5
here it would be an easy blunder to make
it actually does not be out of the game
because Rook takes E5 King takes G2 we
take the bishop and we have three pawns
for the minor piece so black may not
even be that much worse but obviously
why not take the Rook if we have the
chance to do that that's another
exchange another benefit of this move is
that white now has a big choice of
recaptures and already he's down below
three minutes so that's gonna be more
time that sunk into making that decision
and it's not an easy decision to make
because all three recaptures look
relatively reasonable
I think the best move is probably to
take back with a knight the most
intuitive is Rook takes up one but
notice that there are two pieces two
minor pieces aligned on the e-file and
both of them are undefended so Rook
takes C5 is a rather massive threat it
might not win a minor piece because
white can defend the bishop in several
ways but it's gonna White's
pieces even further and they're already
quite past it to begin with Knight takes
F1 our opponent playing well
now we have to decide how we're taking
E5 Pawn takes Pawn should be ruled out
because that just blunders the pawn on
the ec5 so should we take what the Roku
should we take with the bishop well
that's a good question to answer that
question we have to know what what is
our fear like what
is the high level assessment here well
the only major positional drawback of
our setup is that there is a big hole on
D5 and of course we had to account for
that when we played the move C5 that was
the positional drawback of that move
uh so if possible we'd like to prevent
whitesnite from parking itself on D5 I
don't think that's really possible the
only way we can do that is by taking
with the bishop and then meeting Knight
F4 with Bishop takes F4 but the medicine
is worse than the disease I really don't
want to give away our fan Kevin Bishop I
I really want to keep our minor piece
because it's the only minor piece and we
should just keep it
so that rules our options Narrows our
options down to one which is work takes
E5 and of course we're gonna have to
live with the consequences of white
playing Knight F4 and Knight D5 it's not
the end of the world we will work around
the night
also I like Rook takes C5 because it
makes space for the other Rook to join
the battle on the only open file as I
always repeat when there's only one open
file
and there is only one open file remember
the H file and the file are are
semi-open files essentially they're only
open for one person you can think of it
that way which in this case is white
the e-file is the only genuinely open
file because there are no pawns on it
Rogue D1 okay so our opponent does not
bother to improve his Knight instead he
improves his Rook well obviously I'm
salivating at the prospect of harassing
these minor pieces our next move is a
no-brainer we can play it almost
instantly Rook a to E8 obviously it's
not gonna hurt and we are now
threatening to take on E3
and to give you know to win two pieces
back for the Rook
and if white takes on D6 for example we
take on E3 and at the end of the line
you might say oh don't we get checkmated
with Rook d8 no because when you have a
feeling Bishop you don't have to worry
about back rank checks as much we can
cover with the bishop bishop f8 and
we're gonna have to untangle a little
bit there but we're we'll be up two
pawns right now we're up three pawns we
will be up two after Rook takes D6
that's a technically winning end game
for sure now of course white can Def and
probably will defend this bishop Rook D3
okay great
and now we need to keep our foot on the
gas pedal we have like maybe a narrow
window of opportunity while White's
minor pieces are still really really
tangled up so we want to make use of
this in order to provoke more
concessions and you know and and really
squeeze the opportunity out and I see a
nice move that we can play which is a
move that we prepared many many moves
ago and it's important not to forget
about ideas this happens very often
where you make a certain move that move
has an idea your opponent prevents the
idea or you move on from it and then you
forget completely that this even exists
now you guys don't forget that it exists
because you're very attentive and that
is of course the move B5
now what does B5 achieve well of course
if white takes on B5 then we
Force white to relinquish his control
over this very important D5 square if
white does not take on B5 then we in
fact will take on C4 and isolate white
C4 Pawn which we can then attack by
inching our Rook up to E4 and remember
because white has to keep an eye on the
bishop this is where White's passive
pieces really hurt him he can't defend
the pawn with Knight D2 the White's
starting to stumble and trip on a trip
over himself there
also B5 is a very low risk move because
it has no drawbacks again if white plays
Rook takes D6 we play Rook take C3
Knight F4 great move our opponent
playing very well
but I think we can start collecting okay
so we play BC
now perhaps you might be tempted by Rook
takes Bishop Knight takes and then
Bishop to D4 but this kind of stuff
never really works
uh because white has too many eyes on
the E3 Square
so of course we play rookie four this is
our whole idea
and this idea Works to Perfection white
wants to go Knight D2 cannot because he
drops the bishop that is why I think the
only move for white to keep his position
together would have been to play King F2
here preemptively defending the bishop
in order to be able to play Knight F1 to
D2 but that's high level stuff and he's
got a minute left
so we're continuing to put serious
pressure we threaten to take a fourth
fawn
on C4
now the game is not over because even
after we take on C4 of course white can
respond by taking on D6 now he goes King
F2 okay we need to take on C4 and white
takes on D6 but this trade-off has been
a very positive one for us because now
we have something called a pass Pawn
and that we have greatly
diminished the effect of white planting
a knight on D5 because that square is no
longer controlled by a pawn and we've
now like we don't even care about the D5
score anymore our pieces have have
graduated from that so of course Rook C2
check and Rook takes A2 comes to mind
then white might take on C5 so here the
play becomes very very concrete
um and we've got a couple of good moves
here I think we can even play like a
combo like A5 to protect the pawn
I like starting with the check
but then maybe white drops Back The Rook
let's think about this for a second
no no this is not this is far from an
elementary win we do have a material
advantage but it's not it's not easy
because our pod majority on the king
side is has not made its presence felt
just yet
let me think about this I want to come
up with a clever idea
I have a very clever idea that might
work out it might not
I think it will let's think about this
it involves a little bit of calculation
and a lot of moving parts
okay I have a really pretty idea let me
play the move because we I don't have
time to explain this right now I don't
have time to explain this right now H5
is what we want to start with this looks
like an elementary blunder like I'm just
giving away the A6 pawn and why on Earth
would I not go around and take A2 I do
think Rook C2 check was the best move I
will claim that loud and clear I think
Rook C2 check is what I would play in a
classical game
but I think I have a really really cool
idea that I'd like to showcase
which will work only if white takes on
A6 and if I've calculated it correctly
but Bishop before I'll talk about after
the game Bishop D4 again
who is to say the black benefits from
the trade of Bishops because then these
weak dark squares on the king side might
hurt us later on even though without the
Queens white can still access them with
his Knights
so H5 is a very tough move to deal with
because our opponent is trying to
decipher what we want to do he might
have figured it out and now starts
panicking Knight to two okay
Knight T2 is a bit of a panicky move
because it compromises the safety of the
bishop
and it forces our Rook to move but our
Rook wanted to move anyway we don't mind
moving The Rook up to C2 or to the side
Rook to A4 also very good I think both
of those moves are great because our
opponent is in acute time pressure I
think the move which is likely to win
fast is Rook C2 because our opponent is
very likely to take on A6 here and that
loses on the spot
that loses on the spot we're very very
close to just being able to win a minor
piece here
two seconds our opponent of my flag here
King F3 best move I think wow
we can play Rook takes A2
and we will why not let's take this spot
now we have four pawns and a rook for
the minor pieces and again Bishop takes
C5 loses
or at least I think it loses 94.
okay this also loses I'm pretty sure now
here we basically just need to make sure
that White's minor pieces are as
compromised as possible
are as compromised as possible which
which by which I mean Rook A3 is very
strong I think
is it though yeah Rook A3 is very strong
because it prevents the further motion
of this Knight
we are ganging up on the the bishop on
E3 and remember white can't move his
King back
man our opponent is finding all the best
moves here in time pressure so he's
making it hard on me but we'll win so
let me think about this for a second
basically all I have
okay let's step away with our King
step away with our King so that this is
not its shock anymore
another really good move man
okay
go here
I blundered wow he's playing he's out
playing me in sign pressure
okay let's go back I still think we're
gonna win because the blunder will come
eventually
hopefully
but the the
man
players are
seasoned in time pressure
we have to take
okay we have to take now I think white
has to take that was a mistake that was
a blunder the thing is the blunder
happens eventually now of course we have
rookie seven and we win a piece
now we have rookie seven and we win a
piece that was an impressive sequence by
white I made some mistakes there but we
were never like in danger of losing
okay let's not engage in the tiresome
routine of accusing people every time I
say that they play well
it's it's stupid um now we have a rook
in three pawns versus now the win is
very simple as long as we don't blunder
up
yeah no our opponent played very well
but
eventually collapsed okay so how do you
win this type of position
it's hard for me to like lay it out
verbally essentially just need to keep
improving your pieces and make moves
that Advance the general cause of your
position of course if you can trade one
pair of minor pieces here it makes it
easier so a lot of you would go Bishop
D4 but white can reject that trade so
you don't just want to hunt for a
White's Bishop you want to just sort of
improve one easy thing we can do is move
the king up to G7
and then start pushing our Pawns in kind
of a a measured way Bishop B5 in order
to pressure the G3 Pawn
and then we can start pushing F6 G5
sword King G6 just like step by step
expansion on the king side is the best
way to win this position of course
keeping a very close eye on Forks
that's like so so commonly what decides
games in the tragic
you know it leads to their tragic
outcome King E4 so this is not scary
because we can move the Rook laterally a
good practice in time pressure of course
when your opponent has a bishop is to
move the Rook to the square opposite The
Bishop's collar it increase decreases
the likelihood that you accidentally
blunder it that's why I move the Rook to
B5 and not to A5 obviously Rook C5 would
go into the record one that's it okay so
now
you don't want to get too fancy by the
way another thing we could do is just
pin the bishop with Rook B3 that's an
easy win because white is now forced to
give up the G3 Pawn
in order to
release the pin and we are threatening
Bishop D4 white has to bring move the
king up or down and in either case we
can take yet another Pawn now you can
play Rook take C3 here you could give
the exchange up and clarify things and
obviously bishop and three pawns against
Knight is winning but I think people
overdo this you don't need to give up
material just to give it up just because
you fear one check Bishop D4 check I
mean come on F6 or King G8 who who gives
the damn about that I would even go King
G8 because F6 maybe there's another
check on E6 so I would just drop it back
to G8
and then we can continue pushing with h
core completely winning completely
winning here
bro okay Knight F3 again Rook takes F3
as possible but F5 check is a little bit
better because it forces white to lose
contact with the Knight and then we are
up a full Rook
wow very interesting game actually
and a lot of our games past 2000 have
been have been close honestly close
games
I can't say that I'm winning with like a
lot of room to spare
Gigi
so I could talk about the opening of
this game for a long time but I'm gonna
restrict myself to some targeted
comments
uh let's check I know people want to
know the accuracy so I'll check the
accuracy
um as a first row 83.6 to 89.2 so pretty
decent I'm gonna pull up chest face and
use it to give you the opening overview
yeah so this is the fin Keto
uh variation in its traditional form
um and again avrook recommended it as
early as 2008 and since then it's been
gaining in popularity
and um hopefully you were able to
understand why it is that if you are a
pure grunfeld player who is unwilling to
deviate then you should play D5 because
this is your last chance to do that
in the old days people would castle and
white would always go Knight F3
developing the king's Knight first at
some point people just go wait a second
I could go with this Knight and now
you're unable to go D5 anymore so this
way I'm forcing it to a king's Indian so
again is D5 a mistake no this is a
well-studied grun-filled line what do I
not like about it I don't love that the
position becomes quite Bland and to the
liking of a lot of finchetto players uh
how does this line go well typically
white um takes on D5 black recaptures
with the Knight of course
and now
again the the old school line is is just
to develop White's pieces Knight F3
castles castles and this line
has been very well studied since the
time of Gary Gasparov his early career
in the 1970s and 80s this was already
played and the main move here is
actually to drop the Knight back to B6
uh preemptively in order to take the
sting out of the movie for basically the
idea is that now E4 does not come with
Tempo and when he Ford is not come with
Tempo you could bring your Bishop out to
G4 as you do in many grundfault
positions in order to put very strong
pressure on the D4 Pawn in the grunfeld
option Bishop G4 is a better way to do
that than Knight C6 because Knight C6
walks into D5 with Tempo you do do this
in the main line it's just here you have
Bishop G4
so the main move here is Knight C3 black
responds in fact with Knight C6 because
here Bishop G4 doesn't make as much
sense white has this very annoying move
Knight E5 which is why keeping the pawn
on E2 is a good idea and suddenly like
there's threats and you really don't
want to give away this bishop
so after Knight C6 white is at a
Crossroads there is the quiet move E3
and there is the more principled move D5
super theoretical and I never loved
Black's positions in this line I'm not
going to
I'm not going to delve deeply into the
theory here you can look this up
yourself there's plenty of resources
available I will also add that recently
a lot of top GMS have been playing the
immediate E4 which is another nasty
thing that crew and field players have
had to deal with this this is gained in
popularity recently
and the idea is that after Knight B6
white plays Knight E2
very nice setup with the bishop in the
night like this this almost reminds me
of the batmanic setup in the Sicilian
it's the same type of principle where
the pieces don't stumble over each other
when I say Bob Minick set up what I mean
is the setup commonly adopted in
response to for instance the close
Sicilian where yuffie and ghetto your
bishop and then you play E6 to create a
little cubby hole for your knight so
it's the same type of setup after bishop
g292 and it also takes the sting out of
the move Bishop G4 because you could
just send the bishop back with F3
okay
so for these reasons and others I will
recommend the king's Indian against the
fianco and also I feel nostalgic about
and a little bad about not recommending
it in general okay
so Knight C3 D6 Knight F3 again if you
want to check the Wayne's recommendation
in his chessable course I'm pretty sure
it's C5 and from a purely objective
engine standpoint probably the best move
is indeed to play it with C5 but as a
king's Indian player I try to avoid
pushing the seat Pawn to Impossible
because it does lead to a very benoni
flavored position
um and I I like to keep things King's
Indian oriented so I'm willing to
sacrifice a little bit of objective
objectivity for the sake of getting a
position that we're comfortable with
now for a long time as an I am I would
play the the modern move which is Knight
C6 this is called the Pono variation
named after Oscar Pano it also exists in
the samish by the way because the same
dilemma exists in the samish
in the same-ish
uh This Is A variation of the king's
Indian where white plays the move F3
considered to be one of the most
challenging black has the exact same
dilemma of where to bring the Knight and
black can also go C5 here
and the modern the Pono variation is in
fact to play Knight C6 now Knight C6 is
a very provocative move it's a very
provocative what does it provoke well
who can tell what does this move provoke
and why is it that in the king's Indian
Knight C6 often is considered awkward in
relation to Knights that provokes D5 of
course
and it is impossible to play to
improvise here with black things you
have to Simply know what the ideas are
because the best move here is Knight A5
and it's not an easy move to get
yourself to play if you don't know that
this is theory
and so 95 Knights on the rim or Grim
blah blah blah well it's the king's
Indian right normal rules don't apply
it's like California in 1849 or whatever
it's the Wild West
and the reality is that white has a hard
time defending
this Pawn
white is a hard time defending the pawn
on C4 because if white plays the the
natural move which of course B3 and
actually B3 is not a bad move as far as
I remember let me double check
yeah B3 is a move which leads to some
very interesting complications now you
might start salivating at the prospect
of tactics on this diagonal
and these lines that I'm about to show
you will demonstrate how crazy
complicated the king's Indian is the
first move that should come to your mind
is 94. the problem is you cannot stop
here because lpdo these both are
undefended pieces and white wins one of
them with Bishop D2 bang bang no way to
defend both there is also Knight 65 but
this is the same problem Knight takes D5
Bishop takes A1 and again this very
pesky Bishop d2 move
now here the line continues
here the line continues
because who can spot away the black and
tactically try to defend the pieces some
high level games here by the way
but this still loses for black
yeah C6 now Knight takes B3 is probably
the best move but but you're still
you're still giving up a piece right
you're still giving Y2 pieces for The
Rook
C6 is an attempt to keep the X-ray
exchange and it does
but what you should understand about a
lot of grandfather and Kings Indian
positions is that even sometimes white
voluntarily sacrifices The Exchange in
order to eliminate the king's Indian or
grunfeld bishop and those resulting
positions it's like the one I had
against rustamov at the start of the
stream are super super dangerous even if
they're objectively good which this one
is not so why can't play Queen A1 white
can also play the very Savvy move Knight
takes E7 check Desperado attacking the
Knight then take on A1 now the Knight is
saying black has to burn another Tempo
on a weakening move
and what's fascinating about this
position okay here I can win the
exchange back but even if white doesn't
right even if you don't see that Bishop
H6 wins The Exchange back with a huge
Advantage white is up a pawn and blocked
position is collapsing even just
castling is already good for white look
Black's position is in Ruins and it
should be intuitively obvious too how
good this is based on your dominance
over the dark squares on the king's side
it's a destructive exercise to really
convince yourself that a position like
this is good for white even without
delving into it very deeply now you
might be what about Queen takes C2 but
just taking a pawn like this doesn't
change anything in fact it loses on the
spot because obviously here white can
play rookie one Queen T3 and Bishop H6
and the game is over black is no develop
any losing everything
okay
so for that reason after B3 you want to
play the move C5 which often supplements
the Knight on A5 and Black's plan here
as developed by Oscar Pano the
Argentinian giam who sort of develops
this line
uh is to prepare B5 kind of benko Gambit
Style now if White Castles then already
94 is good
because in comparison notice that the
queen is now making contact with the
Knight so Bishop D2 has lost its
Effectiveness and the bishop can
withdraw to G7 if white plays Bishop H6
the bishop can still withdraw to G7 and
the difference here is that white has
also given away his dark squared Bishop
so there's no tools with which to
exploit the weakness of black skin here
White's compensation is insufficient
and for that reason the main line is to
fan get a White's bishop and take this
thing at a 94 and black starts preparing
B5 A6 and the theory here is very well
developed castles Rook B8
but I never liked this I never liked
these types of positions I've always
felt that white can play A4 and make B5
very difficult now black has ways to
fight this and sometimes you see black
playing this benoni style or V6 I've
tried this I've had some good results
with it but this was never sort of my
line
of course D5 is not most common the most
common move is to Castle
and here black plays A6 and again white
has D5 but white can also play this line
without D5 my white can play something
more calm like B3 uh or even E4 is a
move
uh but it's a long story short again
this forces you to play this benoni
style with C5 and I've always liked to
play things more traditionally King's
Indian style and so my move has always
been night beat this up now there's a
ton of theory here and first of all it
should be mentioned that E4 which is the
main line is far from the only
challenging move the second in command
the second most popular move is Queen to
C2
which is a very common move for white in
the king's Indian in general uh bringing
the queen on to a good square and
vacating the D1 Square for The Rook
here by the way the best line is Ed 94
and Knight B6 if you want to know what
the like kings Indian Specialists play
it's this
and suddenly in this position if white
makes the natural movement protects the
pawn of B3 even most G most GMS don't
know this by the way
black develops a massive initiative here
out of nowhere out of absolutely nowhere
does anybody know what Black's move is
here
and I've had this so many times in Blitz
Games especially against like top GMS
because it's not like it's not that well
known the move here is C5 not D5 not C5
not C5 D5 is a terrible move actually
the A5 is a terrible move
Bishop F5 is the right idea but the
wrong execution just giving away the
bishop first you have to chase the
Knight away with C5
then you bring the bishop out to F5 no
and I'm being honest here just to help
you understand how this works so why is
D5 a bad move
well why are you attracted to it you're
attracted to it because you're opening
to center right and you're seeing how
potentially you're opening this diagonal
well you're probably calculating is cd5
which which justifies this move but you
have to get into the habit of not
assuming that captures are forced this
is there's often still a very strong
subconscious pull to just assume that
all of the captures are going to happen
but what is the drawback of D5 well one
drawback is that it opens up a line of
fire to The Rook C5 is possible here
I think after C5 white is better yeah C5
is one very nasty option and then white
can drive the pawn to C6 and you're in
trouble or Y can bring the bishop out to
A3 with Tempo and attack The Rook
The Rook has to move and now I think
white can capture on D5
and after the Smoke Clears takes takes
takes after the smokers if you look at
this position
black is collapsing because the Knight
on D5 is a lot more poorly defended the
queen is x-rayed the White Knight can
jump to B5 and there's threats on C7 and
white has no weaknesses
so
you know so the open Center favors white
here instead you want to push the seat
on C5 the Knight let's say drops back to
F3 if Knight DB5 then A6 forces the
Knight to A3 so most people go Knight uh
sorry most people go Knight F3 and
Bishop F5 and here the tactics work out
for black because E4 runs into Knight
64. familiar Concepts and white is in
big trouble the queen has no good spots
to go to the queen moves to D1
then you can play Knight E4 but you can
also play D5 here and you just have an
avalanche in the center because White's
just unable to complete his development
and now the Rook is trapped and the
Knights jumping into C3 and I've won a
lot of fast games like that so C5 is a
move in some lines yeah here you play C5
to guarantee the F5 Square for the
bishop the best move here is Rook D1
which is very hard to come up with if
you're seeing this for the first time
and the point is to meet Knight takes C4
with Knight cb5
and suddenly the queen attacks C7
through the X-ray of the night if the
Knight drops back you'd you lose C7 so
things get very complicated here black
counter attacks tonight white restores
the material black drops back to you
there's a lot of theory in this line and
I think it's close to equal
but Queen C2 is a viable sideline some
players who want to avoid all Theory
they play a move like B3 or even a move
like E3 is not that bad just solidifying
the center and then the bishop can be
routed uh through the fianchetta I could
talk about this for hours I could give
you sort of all of my analysis here but
there's plenty to focus on in the main
line so that's what we're going to focus
on here
okay so C6 again
tons of theory but H3 is the most
popular move the one qualitative
observation that I would make is that D
takes E5 is the choice of a lot of
inexperienced D4 players and it's almost
always bad this particular structure and
I've talked about this at length before
previously in previous speed runs is
very bad because there's an asymmetry in
the center black is controlling the D5
square but white has no way to control
the D4 Square
and so Black's play revolves around
ultimately trying to get a knight to D4
and I've won a lot of games like this
basically carrying out the plan that
involves getting the night out trading
the light squared Bishop for the Knight
and then rerouting the Knight to D4 or
you could play 98 C7 E64 you could also
play Knight C5 E64 it depends on what
white does
and even if white defends this square
with a lot of his or her pieces it's
still not enough to prevent black from
bringing the Knight to D4 and a good
example game
I'm gonna use the bathroom in just a
second I'm gonna pull up that game
well I don't think it has a name in The
King's Indian it's called The marozzi
Vine but it's in the accelerator Dragon
that's a completely different structure
I call it that informally to just help
you get a reference marker to it
so in this game uh the line that was
featured was a different one
which is the mainline Bishop E2 this is
the called the classical variation
um
and in this position my opponent reaches
the structure right DED is played when
I'm back I'll show you how I was able to
slice them up in the center and on the
king's side
so it should be pointed out in
particularly through non-kings Indian
players this is often a point of
confusion very often this Pawn is
hanging
so um
what does anybody know what what
actually happens after Knight takes C5
and the vast majority of King's Indian
positions what's the Tactical
justification of this
yeah well obviously it's nice well it's
not obvious to everybody right what's
obvious to you isn't obvious to a newer
player
um this discovers an attack on the night
and this the most famous application of
this is in what's called The Exchange
variation of the king's Indian I avoided
it in this game but typically black
plays E5 immediately
and in the exchange variation white
trades queens and normally white does
not take on E5 precisely because black
wins the pawn back with interest with
1964.
um and what people often forget is that
white can Desperado sack the Knight
again with Knight F7
and this is a trickier move how does
black punish this who knows this
nope not rookie eight not Knight takes
C3
Bishop takes C3 Bishop takes E3 check
eliminating the def the attacker and
then you take the Knight
if you take with a knight then you drop
the Rook on d8 and you might be able to
pick up the Knight on Z8 but it's
needlessly complicated
this is hard it's one of the hardest
categories of moves to find is moves
that basically my coach would always
point this out moves where you trade
your fiance Bishop for a knight it's
just unintuitive because it's often
wrong to do that
uh you might remember a Fabiano Corona
game against voice check where he did
did that and people were freaking out
about it here it just wins a piece so
anyways uh 95 is not to be feared my
opponent plays H3 obviously it's 2200
he's not going to allow me to play
Bishop G4 but even without it I gain
control of it first of all I go Knight
H5 and Knight F4 so I get the Knight to
like this intermediate Transit point and
then I drop it back to E6 and that's it
and then I bring my Rook into position
and then I put my 994 like literally as
simple as that and white is already
buckling under the weight of this Knight
as often happens when white takes the
Knight it is replaced by an even more
bloodthirsty Pawn
and then that pawn can move up to D3 and
you can see how nasty this already is
obviously if white takes with the Knight
that white Forks himself so
my opponent was forced to I bring my
other Knight over to E6 to support the
Knight on D4
then I expand a little bit on the queen
side and this is a really really really
nice game then I trade one pair of
knights chase away White's Defender and
stick the other Knight on D4 and I do
that to pave the way for the bishop to
complete the development
and I was able to outplay him ultimately
he lost his patience and took which gave
me control a monopoly on all of the dark
squares and a king side attack and I I
was able to to finish him off eventually
I didn't play perfectly but it was good
enough I mean I just kept pressuring and
pressuring and pressuring and eventually
I drove my pieces into his territory in
one
uh so I could analyze this for a while
but I I don't I just don't want to get
bogged down the way you should
understand is that this structure is
often bad for white because of the
weakness of the D4 Square
okay so back to the game
yeah so C6
H3 and queen A5 old school variation I
actually don't know when this was first
played let me check
this move which was introduced to me by
one of my first coaches like I play the
Kings Indian forever and I've known
about this line forever and for some
reason it's still not well studied I
mean GM's play terribly against it my
success rate
in Blitz in this line is is insane
bronstein played it I think yeah early
Kings Indian proponents so first played
in 1953
Argentinian International Master Carlos
GUI isag boloslavsky played it in 1954
who was the one of the top Soviet GMS
Geller played it he was the like sixth
or seventh
Polo guyevsky Mikhail tall played it in
1958 and beat kodov tall played it three
times four times the tall knew about it
and you can basically see how good
Soviet players were Annie like Cutting
Edge line that is played now Soviet
players were probably the first to play
it they were so ahead of everybody in
the openings that they were just like
the modern day Theory Andes they were
just blowing people out of the water in
the openings
yes okay
so what is the the point of Queen A5
well it's best to illustrate this with
variations first of all
white can play T5
the problem with playing D5 with white
is that after C takes D5 C takes D5
black develops a big initiative in the
queen side and this is one of the
reasons for putting the queen on A5 you
are now able to play the move B5 and you
start driving the pawn down to B4 well
what does that do well obviously there's
an E4 Pawn is that will be lost if white
ignores this threat and even if white
plays A3 you can still play before
because the Rook on a one hangs so
tactically this works out for black and
this is a nasty line
so Bishop B3 is the main move it should
be three is the main move
uh rookie one also by the way rookie one
and Bishop E3 are the two main lines so
I might have messed up a little bit of
theory here let me check something
because I've never the funny thing is I
I've never really analyzed this with the
engine
I've done this very very old school like
this line with Queen A5
I've basically analyzed it entirely by
hand
I've almost I've never made a file on it
I've never looked at it with stockfish
I've just like
learns it through tons and tons of
experience
okay so I apologize the most popular
move here is rookie one and here again
we play e takes D4 Knight takes D4
rookie 8.
we play we play rookie eight which by
the way is not the most popular move the
most popular move here is 95 but the way
I like to play it is rookie 8. white
responds typically with Bishop E3 if you
look at my Blitz Games on my main
account you will find this position
happening a million times
now the best way to defend C4 is Bishop
F1
B3 very common blender tons of GMS have
Blended like this just blundering a
knight in one move
it's not so easy to defend this Pawn if
you think about it if you play Queen E2
then potentially blackened can play this
move Queen to B4
and again B3 not possible suddenly this
Pawn is under a lot of Fire
so Bishop F1 is the main line now we
develop our own bishop and initiate a
trade because we're attacking C4 white
takes black takes and this is one of my
favorite positions in the whole line
this is a big big big calling card of
this line because so many people blunder
In This Very position including and it's
only karpov who blundered in a classical
game against Pia crumbling karpov played
A3 in this position does anybody know
maybe from my Blitz Games why this is a
blunder and this is a beautiful tactic
if you're watching on YouTube make sure
to pause and try to figure this out
because it's really really beautiful and
it's on theme we did something similar
in the game it's just you might not
realize that this is even this might not
even be on your radar
Knight 64 is correct beautiful
now what the hell is the idea why are we
sacking the Knight
you might say oh it's Knight F3 no it's
not Queen just takes the night but again
a beautiful deflection Queen takes E1
this is the Crux of Black's play
Queen takes you one deflection forcing
the queen onto a forkable square
remember that white moved the fianchetto
bishop back to defend C4 which opens up
this possibility and the the
complications work out for black because
after King Jutsu King H1 doesn't matter
King G2 makes it more clear after Knight
takes C1 the Knight on e4 hangs so white
gets two pieces for a rook but exactly
for one move we take the Knight and
we're up in exchange When the Smoke
Clears
does that make sense so of course after
Knight takes E4 white can
Avoid White does it have to take on e4
but already white is losing the center
pawn and if white plays B4 then we play
Knight takes C3
and I've won a lot of games like this
but that's not the only trick
the most common move here online is F4
and here black has yet another beautiful
sacrifice we can still play Knight take
C4
and after F take C5 Knight takes G3 this
is a position which is literally
impossible to play unless you have
analyzed it with an engine deeply and
nobody does that because it's a rare old
line and so you I literally win every
game here with black and the way that
that all of my games continue people of
course play e66 and does anybody see a
promising tactical idea here for black
let's see who can find the follow-up
I'm giving you my deepest and my most
deeply held secrets of the opening
Rook takes D3 exactly
Rook takes E3
now what do you see well what you should
see is that the King of The Rook are
aligned well why does that matter
because the Rook is also undefended so
you might say oh it's Bishop D4 no that
blunders the bishop Queen takes D4 you
actually have to start by attacking with
the queen from C5
very good and this occurred in two games
in the database white has to defend with
something like Queen T3 Everybody Plays
Queen D2 here the engine move is Queen
D3 Queen D2 already loses the game
because the Knight Returns to F5 and the
attack on The Rook becomes totally
overwhelming white can defend it one
more time
but now we win material Knight takes E3
sorry rookie 1963 if Queen E3 white
loses the queen obviously if rookie
three white loses more material to
Bishop D4 and the second Rook is lost
white as busted
white is busted
so to equalize white has to reproduce a
sequence of engine moves here Queen D3
has to be played and then rookie one I
won't delve into it suffice it to say
that you're gonna win most games if you
reach this position white can also not
take on D6 for example Bishop G2 is
sometimes played but now we pick up the
third Pawn for the minor piece and just
look at White's King look at our pieces
it's like massive compensation for uh
for the piece and at this point it's
awkward to talk about compensation
because we're not even down material
we're not even down material so
unfortunately the reason I don't play
this OTB is that everybody knows this at
like a 2600 plus level all especially
younger players the line that really
took Queen A5 out of commission is King
G2 and this was already played against
me as early as 2010 this has been known
for a long time the problem is it
eliminates all tactics related to Knight
F3 and the fact that white has the
bishop pair combined with White's space
Advantage gives white an Undisputed big
Advantage like 0.7 I played this
position online I'm the thing is I know
the ideas so I score well with it but I
wouldn't play this over the board
it's a buzzkill yeah King G2 is a
buzzkill
not the only Buzz skill that's far from
the only Buzz skill
um the other Buzz skill
and I'll open you in on a little secret
very few people know this but in fact
Queen E2 which I mentioned earlier is a
very good move
and after Queen before white has a move
that's incredibly hard to find if you
are not acquainted with this line which
is F4
now you might say well what the hell it
gives up a pun but can anybody find what
is the idea after Knight takes C4
it's it's relatively simple yeah I'd say
it's A3 it's A3 and the queen is
disattached from the Knight because if
Queen C5 then B4 sags you have to drop
the Knight on C4
of course you can do this but you don't
even hear this compensation is clearly
insufficient also your queen is in big
trouble so Queen E2 is another buzz kill
move but it's very rarely encountered
and you can of course still play Bishop
E6 here you can go for the same type of
position but here the bishop is still on
his fan cut out square so there are no
tactics with Knight takes C4 and white
can expand with F4 and then the third
Buzz skill line is what our opponent
played which is Bishop E3 e takes D4 but
I I think Bishop takes D4 is a very
nasty alternative to what our opponent
did
and I-64 is also very good I think 54 is
also very good so I decided to follow
the same scheme of the rookie and here
Rook C1 is a very nice move it's a very
nice move because It prepares the move
B3 Queen C2 is also a buzz skill for the
same reason now B3 is possible and white
is better so maybe there is a better
move in this position I just turned on
stockfish and again I never looked at
this position with stockfish and
according to stockfish the best move for
black is is to play Knight to B6 here
to attack like this
and the reason you play Knight B6 and
not Knight E5
so it's because after 95 Queen E2 is
possible and it's the same line we just
looked at F4 right but if you compare
this to Knight B6 we need to win before
here obvi I mean white can play F4 but
you're able to take the spawn with the
queen
it all makes sense so Knight B6 is very
is quite strong here
white again has a hard time defending
the C4 Pawn the best move for white is
Knight back to B3 very few people would
find this move now we swing the queen to
the other side of the board the Queens
are traded and white is a slight
advantage in the end game but nothing
major it's like 0.6 this is very
playable and white has to find more
computer moves here like G4 Knight F6
Knight A5 so white basically would have
to prepare this slime
um and and practically it's quite easy
to play black hair you can make a lot of
easy developing moves
oh hopefully all that made sense I know
that's a lot of theory but I want to be
thorough and as I've said at the start
of this video and I want to match my
instruction to the level that we're at
so we're at the 2000 level this is a
level at which your theoretical
knowledge has to be very extensive if
you want to improve quickly
any questions
okay so finally we get to the course of
the game Rook c195 B3
and we play the move A6 to initiate the
sort of B5 idea
um
yeah I also didn't know I mean I knew
Knight B6 was a move I didn't know that
it was good
so here Queen D2 is of course a mistake
and you will not believe the engine
evaluation here
you will absolutely not believe it it's
it's almost plus two
so the engine really believes that this
structure is horrendous for black but my
experience convinces me otherwise and
you could see exactly why our opponent
makes one natural move and already white
is much worse
and this happens so often where white
plays good good good good and then
immediately there's a blunder
so the correct move here is not Queen D2
it is what is the correct move Queen
okay G4 is a recommendation nobody would
play that F4 is good I like Queen C2 the
move that would cause me the most
nastiness is Queen C2
because again if B5 then F4 wins the
game C6 is lost here so black has to
play a move like Knight back to D7 for
example
or maybe Queen back to C7 which is what
I normally do and this is a sign that
black black setup is is not all that
successful now I can push the Knight
away with F4 and that is dropped back to
D7
and Rook cd1 for example just improving
the placement of The Rook the Knight is
rerouted to C5
and here's another thing that happens
very very often
very often white responds with B4 this
is like a pavlovian response B4 is a
blunder and again black is already
better here who can sell me why
this is another very important King's
Indian idea that occurs often
not 96 that I mean why would 96 be
better for black
Knight takes C4 excellent and When the
Smoke Clears the two Bishops are aligned
and of course black can attack one of
them at F5
and white will lose one of the very
important Bishops
so white has to play Bishop back to F2
to get the bishop off of the vulnerable
e-file
and here you can understand how Black's
position super cramps there aren't a lot
of active ideas and white can continue
expanding on the king side with G4 but
even this position I would take in Blitz
because white it's so easy to blunder
something here whether it's the e-pawn
or one of the knights it's just a very
practical option for bar
can I check B5 after Queen C2 so Army
Mark asks what about B5 here yeah I can
check with the engine
so B5 here F4
as as per day plus four
it's plus four at 4 Knight D7 I take C6
game is over
no because you lose everything and you
lose not only the C Pawn but also the
b-pawn I mean look at this and the
d-pawn so like this is and The Rook is
the queen is only one square this is a
disaster
oh my gosh yeah this is what you don't
want to allow
okay so Queen d2c5 right and this is an
idea to go into toolkit it should be
pointed out that Knight F3 we can of
course take on F3 and then take on H3 no
tactics necessary
Knight C2 nothing changes Bishop takes
H3 works much like in the game so we can
go to the game continuation Bishop takes
H3 and our opponent plays I think the
only feasible move which is F4 If
instead white plays Queen takes D6 then
as indicated during the game we have
this tactic Rook ad8 giving up C5 and at
the end of the line Knight C3 I'm going
through it fast because I already
pointed it out during the game and we
win the exchange via the fork so the
loss of the Pawn on D6 and this is what
I like is often not as big of a deal as
it seems you can often give this Pawn
away and the the overall Integrity of
the position does not depend on this
Pawn
if that makes sense
and this is the case in point in fact it
helps you to lose this Pawn because it
opens the D file
so F4
and now this is the moment of truth
let's check with the engine oh crap
sorry my computer first for a second
let's check with the engine
whether or not we made the right
decision and I'm going to check with a
high level stock fish on chess space
because this is a complicated position
so I don't trust the chess.com engine
I made the right decision
Bishop takes F1 is only slightly better
for black so my intuition did not lead
me on here
so here is the engine line the F6 Bishop
E2 fg7 this is the position that I was
struggling to evaluate now we have to
move the bishop right so Bishop G4 and
here what ultimately scared me away from
this line
is a beautiful mating pattern where
white goes Bishop H6 and you might say
well this spawn is probably hurting
white but it no it's not because it's
controlling GHA and Fa this is a very
unconventional pattern now let's say
black makes a random move who can spot
the beautiful mating pattern this is
very easy so for newer players this is a
good good chance to practice your
pattern recognition Knight T5 excellent
Knight T5 Queen takes E2 it's beautiful
mate I mean ridiculous I've never seen
this before actually the pawn on shoes
because it's never how does a pawn even
get to G7 it almost never happens
so here black would have to drop the
queen back but but why can still get the
knights F6 is disaster
so of course black black does not
squabry black can play Rook up to E6 to
protect the F6 square but still white
brings the queen into the attack and
then again the Knight is coming in I
would avoid this with a 10 foot pull I
would avoid this with a 10-foot pole so
this is an important skill which is
developed through experience just the
ability to intuitively evaluate these
very unbalanced positions and to
understand
is the material does the material
outweigh the dangers posed to your king
and because I saw this idea I assume
that the answer is yes and even though
black is a little bit better according
to the engine this is very very hard to
play especially when there exists an
alternate option of getting into an end
game so 1964 was the right call
okay so the Smoke Clears we have a bunch
of recapturers and we take on E5 this is
about plus 1.5 which is approximately
what I thought it was plus two even
Rook to D1 and we play Rook Rook aea so
again any questions by the way about the
the the Early Middle game until this
position
how did you come to realize the goodness
the target not the tactics that made it
possible
well the queen is you have to realize
that the queen is a Target because uh
the moment we need to explain this is a
universal tactical concept that exists
across a million openings right I can
this is a blunder that's committed
everywhere
particularly like for example just to
throw with dragon Sicilian comes to mind
the conventional Dragon where in the
main lines very often black does in fact
put the queen on a fine you get the same
the same thing where if you're in
cautious here it's so easy to blunder
this type of tactic I'm giving this is
hypothetical I hear of course why I can
take any so the point is
uh so usually the King on B1
this is the exact same thing right where
you take the two and white takes E7 with
check first and then takes back the
queen certain tactical patterns are
pretty Universal such as this one
um okay particularly with fianchetto
based openings because then your e-pawn
is often on its initial Square
all right
what about other moves for what after
Bishop H3 asks samvanov while other
moves white as a pawn down right there's
not much to say of course can white play
a neutral move like yeah of course
and does the game yeah continues but
here we could for example play B5
already we could carry out our main
concept and we have a huge initiative
because also the king is very weird
the key the key in such positions is
you're almost never afraid of f4 a lot
of people are very afraid of this move
F4 but F4 weakens the E4 Square
and the Knight now has the g-force where
okay
yeah I think I acquired an accent when I
talk about the king's Indian for some
reason
okay so the end game phase I think was
pretty easy to understand Rook ae8 if
Rook takes C6 we capture twice on E3 and
we have a technically winning position
up two pawns again very important
takeaway for newer players is that when
you have a fiancado you often don't have
to worry about the the background check
there is an asterisk though there is one
very major exception
who can tell me what the exception is
what piece could white have that would
change this evaluation
another very important
tactical pattern
dark squared Bishop exactly so place a
dark squared Bishop on H6 and this is a
very classic case of Unstoppable
Checkmate and I have just the
illustration of this I I was able to use
this concept to win a really really nice
game I found a great idea
and by the way it's not all just
situations of the film anytime there's a
Pawn on G6 this is true here is that
example
so this position was reached in one of
my games this came from a Petrov
I sacrificed a pawn as usual for an
attack
clearly the king is weakened you can
notice Black's Bishop was once again
this was fun on G6
using what you just learned let's see if
you can generate a really sexy tactical
move here which looks like a blunder but
is in fact a super strong attacking move
it's easy right this is not supposed to
be aren't supposed to just reinforce the
concept
as all you know initial examples should
I think
foreign
Bishop H6
why does this look like a blunder
because it blunders the queen except it
doesn't Bishop H2 check obviously the
point is using this back rank mate
concept rookie 8 check and this is made
in two Roka favorite Cafe
so by controlling these dark squares you
are ensuring long lasting attack on the
king said my opponent played Bishop f8
trying to smoke the bishop out I traded
Queens planted my Rook on E8 and now the
move that my opponent missed in time
pressure the simple Rook B1 to D1
and The Rook is traveling over to d8
where the bishop is going to end up
massacred so my opponent had to throw
away an exchange in order to remove that
thread and I was able to convert the
extra Exchange in this position
okay
so hopefully
this nuances your understanding of
back rank ideas with the pawn on G6
back to the game Rook D3 B5 uh
increasing the pressure Knight F4 so I I
think I played very very well for a long
time
I think H5 maybe I got too fancy and
maybe I should have just gone Rook A4
and gone after the pawn what was my idea
well who can tell me what my idea was
what was I planning after Rook takes A6
the next move should be obvious from
Context like what could be the idea of
H5 but what's the second move of the
line
this is Advanced this is an advanced
tactic not Rook C2 if I wanted Rook C2 I
would play it on the previous move how
does H5 help with that it's H4
it's H4
this is called removing the defender
what the heck are we doing well
to understand the point of H4 you need
to see this tactic
to see this tactic you need to
understand that contact between pieces
is very important there's two sources of
contact both Rooks are making contact
with the two minor pieces that smells of
tactics
so we removed the defender of the Knight
but one Defender is replaced by the
other except the other Defender is
extremely vulnerable Bishop H6 pins the
Knight and wins the Knight because white
can defend it with Rook F6 this is the
key you have to see King G7
okay you have to see King G7 and now
finally white is out of resources
because the Rook is kicked away so this
line I had to calculate and I checked
with the engine it works so that's the
idea of H5 it's to play H4 and take any
three and play Bishop H6 and in the
resulting position black still needs to
convert but it's an extra Pawn
it's a sexy idea
how did I see this well contact between
pieces right
and
every one of these tactics has has
something that causes or no tactic ever
comes out of the blue there's always
preconditions except
these preconditions can be very hard to
spot because they're camouflaged because
you might look at this position well the
Knight is very well defended right now
and yet you can use the pawn to get rid
of white spawn the Rook to get rid of
the bishop the bishop to pin the Knight
and the King to get rid of White's Rook
so there's a lot of moving Parts here
but hopefully you're able to understand
it once it's broken down our opponent
played Knight D2 forcing our Rook to the
second rank I took the pawn somewhere
here okay I'm making all the engine
moves so far Knight T5 can h8 literally
every move is an engine move
so this was a blunder I I missed Knight
65. so in this position I don't want to
get too bogged down but apparently
Bishop D4 is the top engine move
and the pressure and the tension on
White's pieces gets too much and then we
start pushing the a pawn
okay we have a question to rewind back
to the H5 move
someone is asking what happens if I
doesn't take on H4 well that's probably
White's best move to not take on H4 but
then we forcibly take on G3 and we still
do the same thing
here we can even avoid Rook takes C3 and
probably straight away Play Bishop H6
and ultimately White's minor pieces
starts to crumble right you just start
to like harass them from all sides and
eventually some tactic manifests itself
such as this one
okay
so in any case the time scramble phase
was a little bit sloppy Rook D3 I here
for some reason I thought I had this
move
and I forgot that the Knight defends the
Roxas see I commit these blunders too
but no Panic you just keep the tension
going our opponent blundered in this
position I think white has excellent
drawing chances after Knight takes E8 in
fact I think it's a draw
because
we have to move our rook and sadly we'd
like to defend the a pawn but we can't
play Rook A7 because after Knight G7
King G7 there's a discovery on The Rook
with 96 still a draw because you can
trade off the last Pawn but it's it's
not good so we have to keep we can't go
Rook D6 because that blenders The Rook
so we have to go like to D1 or something
this position I think black has some
winning chances obviously black is the
only one of playing for a win here you
can basically try to slowly Advance your
pawns but white should be able to hold
this white should be able to hold this
of course our opponent finally blunders
and takes the wrong rook and loses a
minor piece because the knights are both
undefended and the first one is on a
light Square so it cannot be defended by
the bishop and it cannot be tactically
defended by the other night sometimes
you there are situations where you can
move one night away and you can't
capture the other one because of some
Fork here just because our King is so
far away there is no such tactic and the
rest is clear without explanation
and that's how the game ended so not the
best ending but I think a very very
tactically rich game a game that allowed
us to illustrate typical Kings Indian
ideas and the actual
climax of the game was short like our
opponent blundered this C5 trick
and after that it was like the
conversion phase immediately afterward
but there was a lot of tactics hidden be
a little bit beneath the surface of all
of this if that makes sense
any questions and please don't be shy
questions about any part of the game
anything that you didn't understand well
or I explained too quickly
I have problems with seeing tactical
patterns and don't learn that much from
puzzles well you're not going to like
this but you just need to do more
puzzles I think people think of puzzles
in the wrong context
right you need to think of puzzles in
the tens of thousands right you once you
do 50 000 puzzles then you can then we
can have a conversation
so
keep it going
why are two pieces better than one Rook
well that's a very complex question
that's by the way not always the case
two pieces can be much worse than a rook
in certain positions the general rule is
the the less other pieces there are the
better for the side of the Rook in
Middle games most middle games two
pieces are better than the Rook because
in Middle games most files are closed
and the Rooks are often just sort of
dormant while the minor pieces can
combine to attack the king
but in an end game with just a rook
against two minor pieces I could
probably dig up some examples where the
Rook is better and as nimsovich
described it in his famous book my
system the reason that the Rook is often
better than two minor pieces in an end
game is because the Rook is capable of
trampolining from side to side very
easily while the minor pieces have a
hard time keeping tabs on everything you
know obviously because they are they're
not as long range as The Rook is
but that's also not always the case like
it really really depends on the position
right and I know that's not the answer
that you know everybody wants to hear
but it's it's how it's how it goes
yeah I could dig up some examples but
this is a separate topic and it's it's
one that deserves its own video
foreign
[Music]